this is justin schmidt yeah my name is
justin schmidt he's an entomologist and
i'm an entomologist
i basically study stinging insects
he's been stung by a lot of insects
i've probably been stung at least a
thousand times he reviews insect stings
the way a sommelier reviews wine pure
intense brilliant pain like walking or
flaming charcoal with a three-inch nail
embedded in your heel which insect was
that that's the bullet ant
this is his lab in tucson
this is his harvester ant
this is his vinegaroon
this is his tarantula hawk these are
some more harvester ants in a park near
his lab
he is the creator of the schmidt pain
scale this schmidt pain scale is
basically a scale to rate the
painfulness of stinging insects on a
scale of one to four a one would be a
sweat bee two would be something like a
yellow jacket wasp the three would be
something like a harvest strand and a
four would be a tarantula hawk
how bad is a four
four it's absolutely excruciatingly
debilitating incapacitating just shuts
you down just absolute sheer
pain there's just nothing you can really
do about that
i don't think i'd want to be stung by a
whole bunch of different fours i don't
think i could endure that for very long
let's be clear justin schmidt doesn't
just go out and get stung on purpose
it's just that he's dedicated his life
to studying well my passion is insects
and stinging insects in particular yeah
i get stung but that's that's all just
part of the passion you know that that
gives me data you know sting
helps me in understanding what the
insects doing
i get to be out in the sunshine and out
in the rain out in the environment
studying these magnificent beautiful
insects
it's just just such a joy
i can't imagine anything i'd rather do
more
you